我借了一首第一次ATR船上的一款款款,只要$400
我用了我的船,食物,全身,全身,我自己的船
所以請你去船上海海海
我現在是很容易船上海海的,我只要看我
今天我们在南海的主义 韩国 韩国
因为海洋海洋航空 已经收到世界上的一种
最初一层的级机器 什么
这一切没有做过
所以我急于买了一票
然后我车载了一整个航空间
全部我自己
所以我会上去台湾的表现
我好想做好
好 大家好
好 既然我一起去
我的帽子也正好
好 你可以坐在这边
你可以坐在这里
好 谢谢
好 让我们去帘录
然后我都给了整个船也
我会给了一个很优先的保护
我也是
谢谢你
你好 她很棒
你叫他叫他
阿良
好 你好 谢谢
你很棒
是真的
我們便到我們身上到達成了
因為我們現在是在瑞 Dang
一個島嶼在南-East Malaysia
但之前我給你一個完整的看法
我們來享受這個美觀看
最美觀看的看法
我們要先解決這個船
我們要快要談談的主持人
Bajaya Group
它不是真的一個船船
但一個商業的船船
是非常有關的行業,包括公司,食物和公司,食物和公司
在此,它是最強的行業,並且在於是在於是最大的行業
所以這船是一小小的事實在做的
ATR-72
And here we are, welcome aboard the Bad Jaya Air.
This is the world's only all business class configured ATR-72.
It has 24 seats in a 1-1 configuration.
It's brand new.
It has only been in service for a week.
And I gotta be honest with you,
It looks pretty, pretty impressive.
They do a lot of charter operation,
但是我还有一些计算机会在 Malaysia
我还在我的买惠惠惠
是一杯酒吧
所以我们看看什么味道
我最初的第一次全新的一家公司是全新的一家公司
我們在背後很小的地方
但它看起來很舒服
小小小層, 水, 水
一大小的衣服
那是一大小的衣服
我可以在第一次
我看了一些很好的衣服
在那些年代的衣服
看了一些 DC-8
或是一大小的衣服
一大小的衣服
这一是很特别的
是一大小的衣服
它是小的小的衣服
我都在生活中有很多事情,不太好
所以我们是半个小时的航空
它是很短的航空
它是50分钟到瑞丹
我只是有咖啡的航空
航空是非常好
我今天有一个很容易的航空
我只是要看我
我只是很容易航空
但是现在是很严重的航空
特别有整个人的船船
你自己的船船
那是一个很特别的船船
但我认为如果是空船船的船船你会有非常舒服的感觉那些船船是非常仍然有非常舒服的感受這些 seats非常舒服,非常舒服
看來的雙方的情況,它不太太好
所以我其實很舒服,很舒服
但是,你會有 USB, USB-C,一點點的東西
還有更多的操作,所以有沒有扣子
这些比较更多的感觉,你可能会知道
通常的ATR会,它可以很硬
在这些人的机会
那是最大的问题,你会有机会的
然后你会有2-2 configuration
但是这里是非常非常非常非常非常非常
它有感觉,它是什么它是现在的
這個桌子是在這裡
然後我們看看這個層樓
如果我找到它
所以我覺得
它是一個很好的層樓
還要留意
有一個人在身邊
但這個
是很美
現在我感覺到
我身上的主席
是在巴ジャー中
Malaysia
很棒的旅程
很漂亮的旅程
你再想?
很趣的事情
看著這款ATR
是否會主要是主要的
或是主要的
服務
我愛它
很棒
我愛當有
有個成功的
人们都觉得,它们只是24 seats
如何是这个维持维?
但这不必要是
我们不必要认为 profit
如何做这些事
但如何能够做出新的事情
可能会成功
可能会有更多船长的船长
我认为这些特别的特别
它是另一顿的衣服
到海洋世界上的一项
它是一件事不太做的
所以,是的,那是很棒的
我愛它
它是時刻到我們來臨
在瑞瀝
我們將會找到海洋
和船上去返回港
我們就開始了我們的距離
到瑞瀝
這是一個短途
但當然是非常適合的
我愛它
好,再见
非常感谢
很感谢
很感兴趣
再见
拜拜
谢谢大家
好吗
我的次命是找到我的船带我回到海岸
我们看看怎么办
好
你需要
是的
好吗
好,謝謝
我去到船船船
船船船?
我沒有留在這裡
他們有牠在這裡嗎?
不,還沒有
我會送你
沒有問題
你確定嗎?
對,因為牠已經在這裡
你已經在這裡,OK,好
好,似乎沒有行車
我真的不知道谁是谁
但他会带我去到Ferish Alman
是它远远的方向?
两公里
好,容易
有依然是会到Tarangano的吗?
你去Tarangano吗?
是的
对
我刚才来到一个视频
对于是空船的
现在我回到KL
是吗?你的朋友说
这个船来到430元
太晚
好
任何游客或什么
我拿到所有的东西
都不错
价格是70元
没问题
只要我一个船
去船空间
现在到摩托车
是的
好久了
45分鐘
好
我還沒預約了一旅程
我會預約一旅程
但我還不確定
我會有旅程
因為有些飛行車
然後
有些人
有人跟旅程
你問
沒有問題
我愛馬來自家
是的
全都很簡單
已经有了
好 来看看我们能够找一个
有很多的楼
有很多楼
你只坐在这里
然后
请问任何楼
任何楼
好 谢谢
这是你
谢谢你
任何楼
我需要去
Murang
然后我搬到船台
好的
如果您到船台
就请任何人
任何人
谢谢
我来到飞行的
而且
他们的设计
他说
我应该问一些游客
我跟一些人一起去海岸
然後我去海岸海岸
然後我還要預約一旅行
然後我會預約一旅行
坐在背後可以嗎?
對,對,對
已經訂閱了, Josh
非常好
我夫人
你好,如何?
好,好,好
好,好
好,謝謝
你很高興
謝謝你
謝謝
今天影片是宣傳的SurfsharkVPN
I have been using for over a decade
so let me give you a few good reasons why you should use it as well
first of all you always have to protect your data
so whenever I go to an airport and I connect to public wifi
my data is at risk
so if I use a VPN all my passports and lock ins are protected
and nobody can hack into my stuff
second reason you know guys I'm a big Schalke fan
and I love to see the highlights of my favorite team
但由于阻止的阻止,我可以看过最好的阻止,我可以看过最好的阻止,所以我改变的 IP address,
我改变的一条,我可以看过最好的阻止,我可以看过最好的阻止,
所以你会看过最好的阻止,它是全世界的阻止,
如果我找到最好的阻止,我会找到最好的阻止,
如果我改變我的 IP address
去低 income countries such as India, Thailand
或是中國的國
我會更多的 flight deals
然後我會 book them
所以, sometimes you save up to $10
然後我會 book 100 flights a year
所以, it saves me a lot of money as well
但這些都是一種的好多的原因
為你需要用 Surfshark VPN
如果用字幕,JOSHCAHILL
和在下面的影片中,
你会有4月的付款
4月的付款
是非常好划算
如果不喜欢它
你觉得它是不给你
它有30天的付款
也有30天的付款
所以要订自一个VPN
看看在下面的影片中
和旅行安全
更多了
现在,我们回到这个 review
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜我先到台北上
所以我們剛到台北上
我不知道完全不知道
但我知道只有一航空空間
在90分钟,从天涵到天涵
所以我将来买到买车或是买车或买车
去抓紧那尾巴
我会写着我的眼睛
那是一个玩意的
我不是哭了
你会
好,好吗?
你去到车?
我去到车,我只要买车
你会在车?
我会在车?
对 会好
全部都会在你的回事
你也会在这边跟朋友们的吗
你只是上三个月
我只是来自 Redang
对 我只是过来
对 这是我
返回 KL
打开完的夜铺
空空空空手
对 那个事
我认为6.30点钟
没问题
你如何是你的日子?
谢谢
非常好
我喜欢听到这
谢谢大家
很高兴
再见
看这个
不错的地方
很普通的地方
所以我們在鎮上,只有一個空間空間
在19分鐘內,是馬來自鎮上的空間
是KL737,所以我們要快點訂這個空間
然後我們回到北京,現在是在香港的空間
今天是旅行的!
你有沒有一個空間空間?
不好意思,他們沒有空間空間空間
謝謝,謝謝,謝謝
是三里面。
和那儿是737-800的船速船的船体,
帮我回到加州。
与一个连郵挡作主。
我的船会。
OK,他们仍然知道我。
但他们常常选择到,他们将来。
是很早。
产年轮延前设定是因为只设计我两个小时。
两个多。
即使是多。
是呀,这次等我设计。
HQ是在做出的工作。
好,很高興認識你
是的,很高興,謝謝你
謝謝你,謝謝你
可以我告訴你嗎
當然,當然
謝謝你
因為我老闆說,請你去吧
好,謝謝你
謝謝你,謝謝你
謝謝你
你好,你好嗎
你好,你好
4F
Hello
I think 4F
Yes
Thank you very much
So here we are on Malaysia Airlines
I literally booked the flight
2 hours ago
And they must have had me flagged in the system
Because they asked the station manager
To walk me into the plane
And I was just greeted here
In a very lovely
Manor
So
但是如果問, 如果你想問, 海洋艦隊友情報道都很好
我們我們稍後往後往 Kuala Lumpur
今天真是有時期尚艦隊友情報道
我真是喜歡ATR和全球第一級的第一級
在一時期尚艦隊友情報道是減少的地方
帶到我們身邊的地方,在海洋艦隊友情報道
是一種美艦隊友情報道
我真希望它們能夠發生得出來
而那些人的網絡在新加坡或是新加坡
我真的可以看到這個作品
像是一個架頭中的主要
那些人想要現在的
但這就是它
請到我的 Patreon
在下面的影片
給我一些新的資訊
我會看到你又來個星期
再次回到另一部航班